today we would talk about a fashion
olfaction is one of the greatest
important sensory modality because smell
of pizza could make you happy or smell
of rose might make you feel satiated or
loved and also smell of smell from a
garbage team can make you angry
so olfaction is one of the most
interesting sensory modality out of many
aspect of our fashion in this video i
will talk about anatomy of the olfactory
system and also the distance signaling
mechanism underlying affection and also
I would discuss how long factory
information is decoded by our brain and
the possible mechanism about it and also
drawing parallels from the current
research and at the end I will talk
about olfactory adaptation however all
factory system is adopted to a
fluctuating order environment in order
to maximize its dynamic range of
detection so if you haven't subscribed
to my channel
quickly subscribe and don't forget to
hit that like button so let's start so
faction starts from the knows where
order molecules mixed up with air come
inside our nose and our olfactory
epithelium is a moist epithelia inside
the olfactory epithelium
there are several sensory neurons known
as olfactory sensory neurons when the
order molecules come to the olfactory
sensory neurons they excite the
olfactory sensory neurons and the
information is transferred to the next
level in the brain that is from the
olfactory bulb to the higher level of
the brain now here is a diagram which
depicts the olfactory sensory neurons or
factory sensory neurons are a peripheral
most sensory layer so these olfactory
sensory neurons have a single dendritic
projection
the norm from there a lot of cilia like
projection appears now on to the senior
of these olfactory receptor neurons if
you see in a details that there will be
specific olfactory receptors
now olfactory receptors are working like
a sensor to detect the odor from the
environment
now all factory receptors are mostly
found in a complex of olfactory receptor
and a co-receptor now mostly this kind
of configuration is true for mouse flies
and also in humans so our factory
receptors are mostly seven transmembrane
g-protein coupled receptor and they are
actually classical GS or G stimulatory
g-protein signaling paradigm so our
factor receptor binds to heterotrimeric
g protein once the odor molecule hit the
green dot binds to the olfactory
receptor the alpha subunit of the
heterotrimeric g protein dissociates and
activates the adenylate cyclase to
generate cyclic a MP from ATP now on the
or factory receptor neuron there are
several cyclic nucleotide gated channels
cyclic nucleotide gated channels opens
when cyclic nucleotide such as cyclic AM
P is there so increase in cyclic GMP
levels would allow the cyclic nucleotide
gated channel to open and allow the
influx of calcium and sodium is etc
positive cations from inside another
individual school of thought also
suggests the olfactory receptor and the
co-receptor could individually work like
an ion channel allowing positive cations
to enter the cell however when cations
enter the cell from outside it would
depolarize the membrane so the dendritic
membrane is depolarized and that give
rise to a change in potential so this is
a graded potential so that the early
first phase of the olfactory
transduction is the change in membrane
potential and this is called a
transduction current now at the end of
the cell body at the axon initial
segment this transduction would be
integrated to form a spike so there is a
spike transduction to spy transformation
and which could be beautifully
mathematically modeled by by your
filters and also the information in the
next part in the axon would be
propagated in form of action potentials
at the end when the action potential
reaches at the end of the Orang terminal
or the olfactory receptor neuron or
mineral it would be going towards the
second level which is a projection
neuron in case of human the projection
neurons are after it cell and mitral
cells and there are also local inter
neurons that gives GABAergic inhibition
to this synapse and we would look at in
a moment but how this GABAergic
inhibition could be very important for
our factory signal processing now from
the projection neuron that means the
mitral cell or the tufted cell the
information is projected to the higher
brain center for example the olfactory
cortex is mostly the most important part
of the whole factory cortex is the
preformed cortex also some part of
internal cortex some pyramidal cortex
and some part of amygdala is also
important for our olfactory processing
now one interesting question is to be
answered which is how the information
about Odin intensity and the quality is
kind of decoded and we can decode it in
our real life so definitely it turns out
the answer lies in the firing rate of
these olfactory receptor neurons so the
firing rate and the firing pattern in
time is very important and maybe those
features are decoded by our brain to
gain the information about intensity and
quality and also assign a
to order whether it's attractive or ever
see or irritating like that so John
Carlson's lab lab in he'll use
Drosophila as a model system to
understand that how olfactory
distinction or how the discrimination
between two orders or how the intensity
is jet determined by double factory
system so fly your factory system just
like a mammalian olfactory system is
very similar there are also all
factories cilia's all around the
dendrites of the of the olfactory
sensory neurons and the odor molecule
you can see here in red will bind to
specific olfactory receptors now why
they use Drosophila olfactory system
because Drosophila olfactory system has
striking similarity with all factory
system of a mouse or our factory system
of a human so the basic architecture is
pretty similar also they have all
factory receptor neuron the first layer
and the second layer is the projection
neuron which is very similar to Mitchell
or the tufted cells and also they have
local inter neurons local inter neurons
over an npn synapses form a gloominess a
cluster of synapses and an interesting
aspect of olfactory processing happens
in the glomerulus so stay tuned and I
will describe that now what they have
found is very striking they have found
if they give several orders to the fly
and record from the slides olfactory
receptor neuron they can get a spike
read the data in format of spikes per
second they saw that if they arranged
this spiking dynamics in a
three-dimensional Euclidean space for
three different orders so what would
happen is if the voters are quite
similar in nature or the smell similar
then they are quite close in a Euclidean
space while order which is very
different would be quite far apart from
the Euclidean space so constructing a
Euclidean space can give us a
understanding that which orders are
similar how a fly or how organism
perceived to owners as a similar order
or towards as a very distinct order so
the distance Euclidean distance is very
important for this discrimination so
this is also known as the distance
discrimination model and I suggest you
to read this paper by Helaman Carlson in
2006 self and the link is given in the
description these researchers also found
that with the increase of dilution of
several orders the discriminability
between orders becomes poor and poor for
example if there are 10 different orders
in the environment at very high
concentration we might think ok this is
the beautiful order of rules that's a
garbage smell and everything all like
this but when there are same orders
present in the environment but a very
dilution so everything is turns out to
be a mixed out something unpleasant or
something like that but we cannot
distinguish Lea tell that this order is
coming from that source and that order
is coming from that source so this might
be a clue for that so what happens at
lower concentration firing rate is also
low so in that situation the euclidean
distance between these several
components are very low so that explains
how discriminability goes low in lower
concentration of order now every day our
olfactory system poses a striking
challenge if you work for a hundred
meters you would get exposed to several
orders for example car smoke food orders
some order from garbage somebody smoking
etc etc but your own factory system has
to code for a sensory modality properly
without getting without getting confused
from these fluctuations in the holder
environment and this task is severely
severely if it
because think about it our olfactory
system has to detect as low
concentration as few molecules in the
environment and also cannot get
saturation saturated a very high
concentration of odor in a environment
in other words it has to maximize its
dynamic range depending upon the
external situation and it has to change
the dynamic range in real time in order
for proper detection of odor
now that's why our factory adaptation
would rescale our olfactory sensations
and thereby help us to detect optimally
for example when you enter a room from
our side you would find there is a
characteristic smell in the room but
after staying for 10 to 20 minutes in
the room you would find you would find
there is nothing different like you
would kind of getting habituate in with
the environment of the room in other
words your nervous system your olfactory
system is getting adapted it is getting
rescale it is changing its output so
adaptation is present in several
different sensory modalities for example
vision similar sensory cortex and any
other modalities so all factory
adaptation helped to modify the
perception towards the smell now how
does a factory adaptation works or
factory or operation could work at
different time scales at different
cellular and molecular changes could
offer for example at very early downpour
for few seconds to few minutes
or factory adaptation would occur by
changing the transduction currents and
the transduction current could be
changed by the change in the
phosphorylation status of these cyclic
nucleotide gated channel a little bit
more time point that is a few minutes to
few second-order then would be
internalization of the olfactory
receptor itself that can alter the
conductivity of the olfactory sensory
neurons in order of few minutes to few
hours there could be change in eggs in
in action potential dynamics because the
truck the level of the ungenerous that
governs that
okay well that governs the action
potential dynamics could also change in
expression now at few minutes to several
hours or several days there could be
change in the transcript level
transcription of the let's say the
factual receptors the channels etc and
etc and also several hours to several
days another important change and
feedback mechanisms could occur at the
synaptic level so we would look at a
little bit about the molecular changes
and also the synaptic component to it so
as we have earlier discussed the
olfactory signal transduction pathway it
has been seen when there is too much
order in the environment and there is a
lot of calcium and sodium influx from
the cyclic nucleotide gated champ and
too much calcium gives a feedback
signaling via calcium binding protein
which in turns reduce the sensitivity of
the cyclic nucleotide gated channel in
simple words it closes the cyclic
nucleotide gated channel allowing
further influx of calcium and sodium
inside the system also cam k2 which is
activated by elevated calcium can give a
feedback to an Italian cyclist telling
it to produce less cyclic AMP II this is
how the gain or the regulator of the
olfaction or factory transduction could
be regulated find a mechanism of
adaptation at the synaptic level it
could be occur in a beautiful way so
let's say we have in our factory system
we have a coding scheme let's say we
have a few five to six molecules that
give rise to a five to six spikes in our
factory sensory neuron for for an
initial type one now as the
concentration increases for several ten
to twenty molecules the spiking rate
also increases but think about a time
when there would be a thousand of or
billions of olfactory molecules in the
environment
what would happen to the whole factory
spiking the new route spike and reach
the saturation but it's not good for the
league on because it cannot maintain its
broad dynamic range so if it saturates
Rd at that situation it is might not be
able to detect a very low concentration
in their government so in a normal
situation here is the olfactory receptor
olfaction curve for example with
increasing concentration the firing rate
of this olfactory receptor in Iran
Dmitry's but if it is too much or
molecules in the environment and there
is no adaptation mechanism present that
it would saturate early way Rd but
adaptation mechanism help to stretch the
curve towards the right hand side that
means it make it difficult for the moon
to saturate even if there is a lot of
odor molecule in the environment and let
me explain how so when there is too much
odor molecule in the environment warden
give rise to lot of acetylcholine is in
the Orang and projection neuron synapses
and acetylcholine whatever
depolarization in the postsynaptic
neuron but when there is too much
activation or too much odors in the
environment the local inter neuron
secret gaba here is a red dot and gaba
allows chloride influx inside the orang
terminal and that chloride influx intern
suppress or in turn interferes with the
physical release process in the overhead
terminal that means even if there is a
lot of stimulus present in the
environment the release from the orange
terminal is sort of regulated by an
inhibitory feedback from the local
engineer or here hereby we can
understand that that negative feedback
regulation is presenting the whole
factory subject and it's not true for
only olfactory circuit this kind of
negative feedback
presenting many sensory modalities and
this set these feedback mechanisms help
help to maintain the broad dynamic range
of detection of a sensory modality
so these mechanism is also known as
synaptic game control mechanism so by
this mechanism of the olfactory tuning
curve could be stretched towards right
and it would be harder for the neuron to
get to saturation in other words the
dynamic range is now increased so that
is kind of a conclusion of my video if
you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you